[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is David Tang knee and we're about
to play some outer wiles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hey guys it's Jeff Keely we are a minute
away from the reveal of crash 4 before
we get to that I want to thank outer
wilds for that incredible musical
performance crash is coming right up
alfe yes that Alf will be joining us and
we also have day of the devs produced by
Double Fine and I am 8-bit look at a ton
of interesting progressive artistic
independent games across the entire game
industry you'll see first look trailers
brand-new footage and some really
interesting games you may not have heard
of but I think you're gonna like over an
hour of content in day of the devs
but right now things are getting started
with the reveal and first look I crashed
for enjoy it
[Music]
hey guys Jeff Keely welcome to summer
game fest we've got a great show kicking
off this week for you I'm really excited
to be doing a yet another week of video
game announcements and other things
outside I've got an extra special
package for yes chief haha Geo
fat keg legs I just mess with you Geoff
Keighley
come on out not this again I'm in the
middle of a live stream right now this
guy always crashing my important shows
I'm gonna see what this is but let me
tell you it better be worth it
crash I really don't want the dirt that
you have on cortex this is the crash for
trailer real fer realz well it's about
time exactly
[Music]
[Music]
how many times have you beaten this
clown anyway three really only three
funny seemed like more that's right
there's the big news crash for a brand
new crash game it is coming this October
and right now I am joined by Paul from
toys for Bob to tell us about the
brand-new crash game Paul we have been
waiting for so long for something new
from crash of course Activision has done
some amazing remasters of the crash
trilogy and CTR but this is a a brand
new crash game built from the ground up
that's right it's it's hard to believe
but it's been over ten years since we've
seen an original new entry into the
series so I'm delighted to finally
unveil this secret that we have been
sitting on for a while it's the
brand-new crash 4 it's about time and
that's it it's a play on the fact that
we've been waiting for so long but also
it's a game that's literally about time
yeah I want to get into it cuz the
trailer is is filled with so much
information I mean you know playable
neocortex cocoa crash but I'm curious
like what you know you guys had worked
on you know the the remasters of crash
but now to start with a new game there's
I'm sure so much trepidation about like
what's gonna be a worthy you know follow
on calling it crash for how did you guys
approach this like what kind of game did
you want to build you know I guess the
first thing is we asked ourselves where
did we want to start and though
technically this is the eighth game in
this series all of the fan reception
that was coming out of the insane
trilogy we've wanted to go back to the
original trilogy and start from that
we're deliberately calling this crash 4
because we want to key it off of the
original trilogy that was developed by
naughty dog that was certainly a high
point in the series both critically and
commercially and so that's where the
events are gonna key off of we're taking
we're starting right at the end of that
when dr. neocortex entropy and Ubu Gore
had been banished to this distant planet
and they finally found a
after many along many many fruitless
attempts they found a way to break out
and in doing so they've torn this
gigantic hole in the universe and
exposed the fact that there's a
multiverse so it's gonna be up to the
bandicoot's crash and cocoa to restore
that order by reuniting the four great
quantum masks the gameplay style I think
you know a lot of people were probably
wondering hey crash in 2020 how much of
it is you know the more linear you know
classic crash levels and of course now
like you wonder like it's an open world
crash game how are you doing it like
tell us about balancing kind of the the
old style of gameplay which is certainly
not broken we love it versus the
tendency to do you know new styles of
gameplay based on the trailer it looks
like you're being kind of still faithful
to the original style of crash versus
making it some big you know the
open-world but is that correct like how
did you approach the actual style of the
gameplay yeah that's absolutely right
and I think what we've heard was that
people have found that style of gameplay
to be really refreshing to return to and
so we wanted to keep of that and when we
observe some of the other games and
platformers and how they've evolved over
time you're totally right they've gone
to a place where they're a little bit
more open in nature and as a consequence
the challenges and things that you
interact with they're a little bit more
sparse and spread out and encourages
exploration and maybe there's a little
bit more focus on collection and combat
but when we think about classic crash
gameplay it's dense and it's focused and
it's really the streams of hazards and
the challenges the platforming
challenges they come in there there's
almost a rhythmic quality to it and how
reliable it is and I know that for me
when I learn a level and I understand
the nuance of the timing and the
placement of all the different hazards
you can enter into a sort of flow state
when do you understand that kind of
musicality multiple playable characters
how are you doing that is it kind of
like by level or high like we saw Coco
and neo playable in there how does that
work for
the scheme of the the gameplay so
crashing Coco you're gonna be able to
choose between them at any point in time
and they share the same loop set over
the course of the adventure you're going
to encounter some new friends some
familiar faces and you're right there
there's gonna be some new playable
characters were teasing today dr.
neocortex he's got a completely
different move set from crash and Coco
so where the bandicoot's kind of barrel
through and they've got the ability to
spin and slide and belly slam dr.
neocortex is uh he's a little bit more
of a cerebral character he's a mad
scientist he's got inventions and he
relies on his intellect if he's got a
ray gun that he carries around with him
and that ray gun has the ability to
transmogrify hazards and enemies into
platforms and he can choose between
changing them into a static solid
platform or a bouncy platform that gives
him access to higher elevations so his
gameplay and the levels that are built
specifically for his moveset is going to
be a completely different flavor it's
going to be a little bit more strategic
a little bit more cerebral
and I think players are gonna have to be
a little bit more thoughtful about when
to encounter hazard whether or not to
trance to change it into a platform and
what type of platform they're going to
need at that point in the obstacle Wow
it it seems ambitious that you're adding
more elements to it and then also you
mentioned the the masks how do those
work so the quantum mask there's four of
them in this game and over the course
the adventure they're sprinkled they're
scattered across the universe you're
gonna have to rescue them from certain
the clutches of certain bosses but
familiar in new the quantum mask two of
them that we're talking about today is
the time mask and gravity mask and masks
in this franchise they've got a lot of
personality they've got their own names
and their own voices and their own
powers so the time masks her name is
kupuna law and when crash uses kupuna
law he's got the ability to slow down
time to a crawl so for obstacles that
are beyond just way too fast to
interface with
at normal speeds he's going to be able
to slow things down and then get past
those obstacles and in addition to that
he'll be able to get past nitro crates
which have traditionally been a one hit
one kill type of thing but with the
power of time he's gonna be able to slow
things down trigger that explosive and
then get out just barely before that
explosion obliterates everything in its
path the second mask is the gravity mask
and his name is eco eeka so when crash
dawns on a [ __ ] he's going to be able to
flip the direction of gravity and walk
on the top of ceilings walk upside down
underneath platforms to get past
impossible obstacles I'm really excited
to play this and again I was playing
crash back when the original PlayStation
first came out when you you know
Activision's done a great job with the
remasters but to have a totally new game
I think is what everyone was hoping for
and you're bringing it to life so
congrats for doing this and thanks for
doing it even for my work from home
situation it's it's awesome to see and
can't wait to get to play later this
year thanks for having me it's a great
pleasure and I think it's an exciting
time for games and I'm so glad that we
could reintroduce crash a new version
and a new adventure at this time all
right there you have it crash for we've
got day of the devs coming up shortly
but right now we are going to introduce
you to summer game fests tech
correspondent he is joining us from
lockdown and I'm really excited about
this please give a warm welcome to Alf
Alf
how is your lockdown going you want to
talk lockdown
I'll give you lockdown for the past
thirty years I've spent every day hiding
from the United States government so
I've got some stay at home gaming tips
for summer game fest
are you ready here they are tip number
one clean off all the fur from your
controller every 20 minutes because
there's nothing worse than getting your
analog
sticks jammed up with hair okay that's a
good one
tip to don't charge your controller in
the microwave bad bad idea
learn that one the hard way tip number
three don't play war zone with e.t all
right he cheats he's a sore loser and he
doesn't know how to use air strikes just
doesn't understand it okay a tip floor
don't wear pants embrace the freedom and
with that it's time to raid someone
stream alpha we've got a whole day of
the devasting still to go we are
certainly not done yet
oh I think you've been done ever since
that Dorito segment can I get some Epson
chat for Kaylee's career its Keeley not
Kaylee Alf but thanks summer game fest
tech correspondent Alf thanks for
joining us Alf will see a little later
right now though we have a special
announcement about something coming new
to smite check it out
[Music]
this world is in trouble we can't let
this happen they need or help
[Music]
[Music]
all right
coming up next is David devs but I
understand alfe you've you wanted to
come back on the stream already since I
have to stream for 24 hours on Twitch to
become a partner I might as well burn a
few more minutes now okay what does she
have in mind house I want to talk to you
about your fancy game consoles because
on melmac we were far more advanced in
gaming technology when I attended reform
school
I majored in software development where
I created what you Earthlings called
Hatsune Miku and no it's not a Saki
alpha we've got Dan the Deb's coming up
could you catch the chase so I have to
admit I was a little confused last week
when I was watching the PlayStation 5
stream and I saw everybody booing and
eyeing about all those fancy graphics
all right now don't get me wrong the cat
in stray looked very nice so realistic
I could almost smell the barbecue sauce
you guys might think horizon forbidden
West and Gran Turismo 7 look great ha ha
on melmac our cave paintings had more
pixels and in our version of Grand Theft
Auto you actually did real time yeah so
I still have three stars above my head
in the Andromeda galaxy just to let you
know I hope you guys keep improving your
games and one day when the fur
technology is good enough maybe I will
finally make my triumphant return to
video games now if you have any ideas my
DMS are always open at least as soon as
my account is unsuspended now it's time
for the day of the devs developer
showcase looking at a series of
inspiring new independent games enjoy
the show and the rest of summer game
fest alright recording the audio here oh
they're dead spider rose and then I'm
starting to video
so I'm starting the video so you don't
start the video saying this at me so I
can do the clap okay got me man ready
okay now don't press Start just wait for
me to go here okay ready yeah okay
action
oh hello there
you caught me airing out my skulls I
need to have them all ready for the big
day of the devs Summer Games fest we're
gonna be showing a lot of cool games
today and you need the skulls to be an
optimum performance all right see
Chrisette this is a child skull
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Day of the Dead
summer game fest showcase we're enjoying
you some great indie games today I'm
letting you meet the developers day the
devs is the show we've been doing in San
Francisco for many years now and this is
a special summer edition coming right
into your quarantined home for your
safety before we get started with this
show we're gonna take a look at the work
of a group called game heads in Oakland
who we've been showcasing at the other
does for a few years and they do
fantastic work so check them out and
think about donating everybody this is
Damon packwood I am the executive
director and co-founder of game heads so
gay man's provides tech training to
low-income students of color ages 15 to
25 we teach game design development and
DevOps but most importantly we are
committed to creating the next
generation of diverse video game
developers we're trying to change the
game quite literally so today we want to
show off some games that were very proud
of the first up is serpent showdown
[Music]
circuit showdown is a light-hearted 3d
arena fighting game it's created by a
group called persuasion games they're
headquartered at USC the team comes from
a diverse range of backgrounds and life
experiences we were very proud that
three of our students are on this team
[Laughter]
next up is triger trigers a bullet hill
mixed with a color matching game that
incorporates in 80's inspired aesthetic
arcade console experience
this was developed by one of our
students Joseph Hooker it's an excellent
game plays really well looks really dope
and it's obviously a lot of fun also be
on the lookout for that one
[Music]
here
[Music]
great soundtrack some really funny
voiceover it's created by an all-black
male team shoutout to Jionni Suarez
Jovan Smith Xavier ward preparing and re
Davis so that's it for me be on the
lookout for more information on these
projects on our social media or on the
social media accounts for the projects
also be on the lookout for our showcase
coming up in August and should be
announcing that in the next couple of
weeks
finally if you're interested in getting
involved in the program as a mentor or
as a student you should find more
information on that on our website
that's it for me thanks you're gonna
want to turn up the volume for this next
one it's from a developer called
Beethoven and dinosaur out of Melbourne
and Annapurna interactive and it's it's
just plain badass it was created by a
real-life rock star with a penchant for
studded jackets named Johnny Jabba Tron
epic it's personal it's just so [ __ ]
cool seriously turn up the volume we
will not regret it
[Music]
my name is Johnny Galvatron from
Beethoven and dinosaur and right now
we're going to show you the video game
that we've been jamming
it's about a teenage guitar prodigy who
embarks on a journey to craft his stage
persona it's called The Artful escape
stuff gets pretty far out but our story
begins on in there's a squirrel in
Calypso Colorado where Francis Vendetti
is on the eve of his first live
performance
Francis is the nephew of legendary folk
icon Johnson Vendetti who's kind of like
this universes Bob Dylan in these
opening chapters of the game were
introduced to Francis's hometown the
staggering legacy of his uncle's Fame
and the impossible expectations of his
fans many of the townspeople have
opinions even memories of Johnson
Vendetti now offer you advice history
and ill omens
[Music]
it's here exploring calypso that Francis
begins to suspect that things are not as
they seem
now it gets cosmic pretty quickly for
Francis in the pursuit of his new stage
persona and we join him in the world of
glimmered in searching for a jazz club
that never appears in the same place
twice
[Music]
out in the cosmic extraordinary
Franciscan Jam on his guitar at any time
using it to Hama through the air nice
slide down slopes and interact with a
musical world
[Music]
the different dimensions of the AH
police cap are alive with creatures and
foliage that will harmonize with your
guitar
[Music]
we wanted the shredding of the game to
feel powerful and effortless the same
way some games depict a mastery of
combat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Frances uses a musical language to
communicate with the interfaces and
creatures along his adventures
sometimes with jazz club owners like
this
[Music]
and sometimes with staggering cosmic
wild things
[Music]
you can customize many aspects of
Francis's persona including his stage
name what planet he's from discuss your
backstory and of course change your
stage costume the omphalos capers are
loving mishmash of rock operas and
adventure games and guitar solos it's
been a journey to create and we can't
wait for the final act thanks so much
for watching that's all we've got right
now except for this
[Music]
so we've been curating de the dev's for
eight years now and it's been amazing to
see the growth of the indie scene since
then and I think you'll see that here
with this next game from frozen byte
starbase and it's like an amazing huge
gigantic game and I think you'll be very
impressed
hello I'm pip I'm Kai and we're from
frozen byte that have been working on
Starbase
starbases our upcoming space MMO set in
the universe of vast scale where
everything is fully destructible
[Music]
in starbase the players can use their
own creativity to design and build their
own spaceships stations factories and
more since the smallest building units a
single bolt even the small ships are
made of thousands of parts each with
their own detailed damage model which
makes building designing and repairing a
truly creative process it's based on a
hybrid or voxel and vertex technology
which allows the players the ultimate
freedom to both create and destroy in
ways where every single time gates and
ladders
[Music]
however damaged ship controls don't
necessarily mean that the journey is
over
[Music]
if reconnecting pipes and cables won't
solve your flight issues you can
manually adjust the truster and
generator values in the engine room and
continue on your journey
[Music]
since Starbase is an MMO player
interactions play a big part of the
games experience you can build and
design ships together selling your
designs to others go on a mining trip
[Music]
or attack somebody else's ship and steal
their car
[Music]
good fault factions build huge capital
stations and engage in massive fleet
battles and try to conquer the universe
together
[Music]
the Starbase universe is infinitely
expanding and players can venture out to
discover station's asteroid fields
raikage's from previous battles and they
might encounter fellow travelers or even
unknown dangers
you can even try your luck at being the
first one to reach one of the faraway
moons
[Music]
starbase will be coming out on Steam
early access later this year if you're
interested in following the development
progress or trying out the game in its
closed alpha stage join our discord
server at discord GG slash Starbase and
don't forget to wishlist the game on
Steam this next one is a collision of so
many familiar trappings done oh so well
it's a retro modern genre visual mashup
it's from big blue bubble at Ontario it
just features some of the coolest most
beautiful sprite animation you've seen
in a while especially that boss battle
you're about to see oh it's awesome I'm
Neha from big blue bubble and be made
for gone
[Music]
Horgan is a fast and fluid to the
action-platformer impact the boot and a
retro pixel art tool in fergan will
slice your way through hordes of enemies
and collect an arsenal of powerful
weapons
all while unraveling the mysteries of
the entity known as the herald
Halligan's first king back when it was
still a kingdom
Horgan has been a passion project here
at the studio for the last few years
after making mobile games to the better
part of a decade we wanted to make
something that reminded us ASSA games
[Music]
we took cues from innovative games like
dead cells to create a modern take
classic pixel platformers by using 3d
animation to create a 2d experience that
feels great
inspired by classic games such as Prince
of Persia and Castlevania we wanted four
gone to be a handcrafted adventure that
players would progress through while
unraveling a compelling story
we were also inspired by games like
Diablo where your character progresses
through the game by discovering a rare
loot that helps you defeat mobs of
enemies across the world
you're in early access on the epic dude
store we focused on expanding the scope
of four gone most recently with our June
update which introduces and all new
biomes the creepy catacombs filled with
new words of enemies and two new boxing
it's been great watching the world of
Corgan evolve during this time and I'm
excited for people is what else we have
in store as we lead up to our launch on
switch PlayStation and Xbox this October
we hope you guys enjoy the game next up
is a psychedelic furious art driven
platformer which is a real meeting of
minds from art to a code to music it's
real fun to stare at the melty trippy
graphics of this game allow me to
introduce you to spin ch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Jesse Jacobs and I'm the
creator of Spanish in partnership with
Queen became
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] was a secondary platformer game
based on my artwork you play as a spinch
and you're on a mission to collect your
missing baby
[Music]
because it may seem cool but spinch
babies are used as animal against the
bosses
in this age of mass production art plays
a very valuable role and speech was
created to reflect these values
[Music]
hey I'm James Kirkpatrick I made all
these songs and the action sounds for
the game spinch I used a modified
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next up is Inglot from nifflas they've
been making games for over a decade like
knit and they made this beautiful
audio-visual soundscape that is a
platformer with no platforms hi I'm
Simone Stoll henskee and I'm the
colleague of nifflas who's the sole
developer on ended nifflas is known for
working on games such as compute
underground earning and affordable space
adventures both of us are from the small
Copenhagen based studio triple topping
games in Denmark you've jumped between
bubbles that float in the sky like your
space dolphin and all the while you melt
into a highly reactive and dynamic
soundtrack created by England's custom
and needlessly complicated music soft
[Music]
moonlit is a platformer with absolutely
no platforms if you aren't resting in a
bubble for a moment you'll be doing
acrobatic dashing bouncing and rail
riding to keep from plunging into the
void difficulty is fluid in Newman with
the granular difficulty settings you can
find the level of challenge that suits
you
England has dynamic save points you
decide whether to stop take a little
break and set a respawn point or whether
to blast daringly through the level
putting everything on the line
[Music]
and that has Copenhagen blood and it's
beings each level in England is based on
a location in the capital of Denmark
where our studio is also based and in
each level you'll need to find one of
your little friends and help them get
home also has biting sports
lots of achievable x' an upside-down
world extra many levels and lots of
railroad tracks a non platformer to look
forward to if you really like that
former games
[Music]
our next game is called skate story and
I know what you're thinking
EA motive just announced the sequel to
skate but skate story is not that except
it has the same reverence for real
worlds
you
deboarding but it gets weird it gets
real weird you'll see what I mean state
story is a game about skating down into
the other one you play as a glass hater
trying to reach the center of the
underworld the world who skate story is
filled with beautiful architecture that
sprawls out every direction there are
nine layers underneath New York City
each of them governed by a sentient moon
you'll meet weird characters like footed
demons or rusty frogs and you talk to
the moons in the sky
I'm trying to show skateboarding in a
different sort of light I want to skate
across beautiful otherworldly structures
and kickflip over a forgotten God's
statue and
[Music]
I grew up playing a lot of the classic
skateboarding games by Tony Hawk riding
around the warehouse in schools for
hours state well Ollie ollie or even new
Indies such as session or state or excel
the control scheme of skate story is
weird mix between all of my favorite
escape games this gate story you have to
shift your weight before you do tricks
so for example in real life in pick
lifts you have to composition of your
foots over here where you flip the board
to pick so opens it story University
see how it mirrors real life
still working on the games and hopefully
you like what just thanks for watching
[Music]
all right next up is a game that
exploded on Kickstarter recently called
Black Book a deck-building adventure
game set in kind of a Slovak full core
setting looks terrifying hello i'm going
nvidia to keep from mark jóska
the studio behind black book black book
is a story of a young witch who just
recently received a knowledge of dark
arts with her you will travel across
mythical authentic landscape of 19th
century Eastern Europe and encounter the
mythical creature
some of them friendly while others not
so much
the game is built around troop slamming
folklore a short story called village in
the native town
[Music]
in this tourist people tell about
allegedly through meetings with spirits
and demons this store is on with the
real region of children inspired us to
create a setting where people to exist
and sometimes even meet with
otherworldly beings some of which might
never before efforts in popular culture
[Music]
at its core Blackwood is a deputing RPG
a similar to slay the spire and mixed
with old-school adventure games
[Music]
[Music]
we took extra care to make sure that the
core gameplay supports our narrative and
the narrative itself is as authentic as
possible
[Music]
[Music]
which have their own structure has their
own goals and we try to convey that now
again we feel that the unique Slovak
sailing and its lore have great promise
when it comes to
[Music]
[Music]
women went as far as to avoid adele was
professional at not refers and
folklorists to help us views and in game
it's like EDM and bleach and reductases
the general reach here as well as
russian folklore in general
underrepresented
[Music]
you can use your own deck of spells and
counter mythical creatures and you will
reveal all the mysteries of the
blackboard
[Music]
[Music]
breath blackbook is both a game and a
cultural statement we hope to show that
in each fault learn from all over the
world can inspire bring suspense and
emotions to gamers even today this next
game is all about teaming up with your
friends to defend a village of vegetable
pals from being eaten by a wee beasties
from the outside it's made by the
molasses flood who were really good
friends of ours at Double Fine and
actually helped us out a lot with
Psychonauts
- in the early days this is Drake Hollow
hey my name is Forrest Dowling and I am
the creative director on Drake Hollow
and this is Liu who will not stop
pestering me because she hears me
talking so she gets to sit in my lap for
this Drake Hall is being made by the
molasses flood a company I co-founded a
number of years ago and we're best known
for the flame in the flood which was our
only title thus far but I'm here today
to talk about Drake Hollow
[Music]
all right who's got the chest Oh Canada
oh we call it an adventure action
village building games so I think today
I'm going to head the southeast gonna go
try and find that lighthouse when we
started working on this we had
previously worked on pretty hardcore
survival game and what I wanted to try
is just making a game that explored a
lot of the same ideas but it wasn't so
much about you surviving as it is about
you taking care of something and helping
it survive it's a game about taking care
of things and that's where the concept
of the drakes came about they're sort of
the heart of the game they're these kind
of charming little vegetable goblin
creatures that are kind of dopes like
they need your help they they need you
to build in places to sleep and provide
food to eat and entertainment for them
seems like Drake's could use a little
more entertainment straight to the disco
floor of course favorite it's your
masterpiece oh are you gonna dance oh
yeah so your job is to do all those
things that to take care of them and you
can bring along your friends for as well
so if you want to play Clough you
certainly can and it's a really big part
of the game it's something that's been
one of the pillars since we conceived it
Oh
[Music]
oh no I'm out of decoys
[Music]
oh yeah he he didn't go after the decoys
there's exploration there's building
there's rescuing Drake's and there's
battling monsters so I hope you enjoy it
it's not retro throwback games are all
the rage but they are hard to nail 8-bit
16-bit era stuff not all developers know
how to do it right but there's one in
particular that we've been showing just
the very beginning of day the devs eight
years ago
their name is tribute games and they're
out of Montreal and fun fat's the core
creatives that made the Scott Pilgrim
game in a house at Ubisoft broke away
and found a tribute here's their latest
retro opus
hey everyone my name is Frederick
gemma's and I work as a designer at
tribute games and today I'm here to
present you our latest game Panzer
Paladin massive weapons are raining down
from the skies releasing hordes of
demons and it is your job to travel the
world and stop them from invading the
planet
today we are visiting Egypt where we'll
be fighting Anubis the weapon keeper of
the region oh and as you noticed the
game is boasting some pretty rad pixel
art visuals for maximum nostalgia
triggering goodness in Panzer Paladin
you play as grid a giant power armor
equipped with the latest technology grid
is able to fight the demons by using
their own weapons against them as you
fight your way through the game you'll
discover hundreds of different melee
weapons each weapons fall into a
different melee category like cut or
impact making them more effective
against different types of enemies each
weapon is also Indian with different
stats and spells by breaking the weapon
no cast spells in that case a sweet
healing spell ask for weapon attacks
well you can use them to do downward
stabs and bounce on enemies or do a
rising attack which acts as a double
jump or you can simply throw em at
enemies face to deal massive damage but
watch out weapons do wear down keep an
eye out for your weapons durability see
my weapon broke but no worries there are
plenty of weapons to collect all around
the game throwing weapons at enemies or
breaking them to get follicle cells is
part of what makes Panzer had it in so
much fun but perhaps your greatest
weapon in the game might just be flame
this choir that pilots the Paladin from
the inside she can eject to stick into
tight spaces or to recharge the power
armor when it's low on energy using
those tanks she can swing from rings
with a laser whip before using to strike
demons as well but and can't see she
can't pick up the demonic weapon as
our grid can do so plane can eject at
any time and you could even play the
whole game as er if you'd like you can
sacrifice a weapon at these pedestrians
checkpoint checkpoint so well worth it
mainly when you encounter creatures like
this one this is the horseman if you
hoard too many spirits weapons the
mythical creature will come to fight you
perfectly tank block followed by an
attack will open up any enemies defense
and create a fairy you can also use the
back - a lot in quick moves that will
touch almost any attacks especially
those unblockable energy attacks the
arts man is a powerful enemy that you'll
encounter multiple times in the game
truly challenging your swordplay skills
as you progress and by defeating the
horseman you will be rewarded with the
mysterious weapon from the blacksmith a
weapon created by the community with the
blacksmith you can forge anything you
want you simply need to try to pixel art
using our sample to use tool name your
creation and allocate the points to the
different parameters and spell well
saved your friends family and the whole
Panther of the Latin community will have
access to your pixel crafted armory
several slice of world record in the
speedrun mode replay all levels and try
to beat your friends time the
community's best or just your own find
shortcuts maximize combat techniques and
discover new ways to save time
earn medals and place your name high up
on the leaderboards Panzer Paladin is
packed with 17 carefully crafted levels
each with a unique bus protecting a
powerful weapon for you to seize by
completing your first run of the game
you'll unlock the remix mode where you
can access alternative versions of all
of the levels upping the difficulty and
doubling the fun yup that's a whole lot
of side-scrolling action the game is set
to release this summer for steam and
Nintendo switch so keep an eye out for
tribute gangs on all of the major social
networks and at the game to you
witness hope you enjoy today's
presentation and stay safe everyone know
your stream is not broken for this next
one it's definitely in black and white
there's not a lot you can say about this
game it's super unique it sounds awesome
and it's unlike anything you've ever
seen before
and it's from a developer named games
for ghosts which is a name that will
make sense in about three seconds
hey this is John davut from games for
ghosts and I'm happy to present
work-in-progress computer game on to
garage owner garage has been in the
making on and off since about 2018 and
is created by myself and Richard
Peterson
I handle the artwork sound and creative
direction and rich it makes it all
function and magically come together on
the programming and technical side
Hunter grouse has taken many forms in
its evolution over the years and what
started out as curious experiments with
drawings and sounds has turned into a
music production adventure game
taking inspiration from games such as
Myst King's Quest plug-and-play - Sammis
3 written I eventually decided to put
all experiments under one roof
interconnect all these disparate
audio-visual tourists that allow you to
create an evolving
[Music]
so is this a spooky game well not really
it's haunted and
in the sensitive not exactly sure who's
in control or what the state of reality
or context is
and garage as in a place where dreams
are realized
[Music]
[Music]
not to mention and practice you're also
creating your own evolving soundtrack to
the strange little pixel adventure game
where you explore and discover new
instruments and artifacts to add to your
collection
[Music]
this game is definitely about making
music but it's also about puzzling over
and manipulating these little
contraptions we've designed to have
limited functionality with many
variables and combinations
[Music]
on the garage aims to allow players to
have a comfortable creative experience
unlike traditional digital audio
workstations that can overwhelmed
beginners easily the instruments in
order garage provides you with fun and
non intimidating environment to become
acquainted with musical concepts while
also providing enough room for more
experienced musicians to flex their
creative skills within the limitations
[Music]
so far we have only really scratched the
surface in terms of what we want to make
possible and we have a substantial
amount of Tobias's artifacts and
interactive vignettes that have already
been designed and waiting to be
implemented
besides adventure mode we plan to
introduce other game modes that will
allow players to construct and capture
their own full songs and packaged
releases owner garage version one is by
no means a finished product and many
corners still need to be ironed on but
what we have achieved thus far as the
groundwork for what we see as exciting
new adventure gaming experience where
there it's just about going along for
the ride and adventuring or spending
hours mastering your skills and crafting
your perfect little jingle and sharing
observing
[Music]
[Music]
next up is the internal cylinder from a
steam and chilly they've been making
games for a long time all the way back
to Zeno Clash and they have a very
unique personal house style I think
you'll see reflected here it's a bonkers
game
hello I'm Carlos Bordeaux from the
studio a steam the people who made Rock
of Ages and Zeno Clash and I'm here to
talk to you about the eternal cylinder
our upcoming game
it's an adventure survival game but very
different to anything out there on the
market you play these little creatures
called the treble there's like a family
of creatures who are born this very
surreal and alien world the main main
obstacle main thing about the game is
that it has this huge cylinder than
which is crushing the entire world
destroying it
and you have to keep on moving forward
and discovering about your family the
your race what's going on on the world
where where does the cylinder come from
[Music]
this time the discovery of a new statue
when the knowledge it grounded was not a
surprise but a welcome sign that there
was someone waiting for the Trebek as
soon as they completed the trials of
course as was only appropriate
[Music]
it's definitely a big game and an
ambitious type of for a steam
[Music]
[Music]
we really want people to explore this
world and looking forward to completing
the project
[Music]
you've probably heard a flow flower
maybe even journey they're called that
game company and their latest project
has been an ongoing social experience
experiment that's that's gathered the
attention of a lot of players
it's altruistic its compassionate it's
exactly the kind of hopeful gameplay
experience that we all could use a
little bit of right about now and
they've got an exclusive first look at
something they've been planning for a
while just for day of the devs well and
some are game fest thank you
we're excited to see what indie creators
and studios have been up to it is always
great source of inspiration and a bit
eerie charge but hard-working indie
developers we're so proud to see the
fast growing in the community and filled
with gratefulness from the amazing
players worldwide who have been
supporting us over the years as sky
approaches when your anniversary will
launch a new season which comes with new
stories characters and most importantly
a relaxing vacation that we all miss
leading up to Sky's first birthday we
announced more surprises until then
please enjoy this teaser season of
sanctuary thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it's no secret that the team at Double
Fine loves a really good point and click
adventure and this one from Wales
talking interactive looks like a really
really cool expression of the genre
it's moody it's woodsy spooky and it's
really beautifully animated this is the
night is gray hey there hope everyone is
doing okay my name is Andrew brow and
I'm the creative director at worst orc
interactive I'd like to show you the
ninth is gray
in this cinematic thriller we play as
Graham who is being followed by strange
wolves in the woods until they finds the
cabin meet a little girl abandoned by
her mother suspect the worst happen and
now you're responsible for the child's
survival in a strange night that keeps
getting stranger who tried for a
somewhat surreal and creepy living
lynching
[Applause]
besides being a lovable character Anna
is also part of a game again as
exporting errors in some different
puzzles with the help I have to switch
from playing on your own to carrying her
around like any adventure game you have
to solve puzzles to progress
no pixel hunting we promise we are
trying to reach the sweet spot between
frustration and accomplishment by
changing up the case
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
today the devs gives us a chance to
highlight three personal stories from
developers who have a unique point of
view and this title from super hot and
Australian developer Andrew Brophy
really is a good example of that it's
super weird
welcome to the messed up future of
knuckle sandwich hello my name is Andrew
Brophy I'm a game designer from
Melbourne Australia I'm very pleased to
have the opportunity to show you what
I'm currently working on it's a video
game called knuckle sandwich
[Music]
[Music]
I would describe it as a personal game
hiding inside an offbeat turn-based RPG
it's set on a fictional island of the
southeast coast of Australia where
players will find themselves assuming
control of a young man who moves to the
island and gets wrapped up in the lives
of all the people that live there
along the way you'll have run into the
dangerous gang a fanatical cult and a
heap of other Island residents as I
mentioned earlier knuckle sandwich
reaches 10 base battles they function
pretty much exactly how you would expect
except all special abilities are
replaced with huge variety of mini-games
[Music]
anyway that's knuckle sandwich in a
nutshell I hope you dig it thanks this
is a really exciting one to end on nice
final beat here see of stars from
sabotage the creators of the messenger
fans of Chrono Trigger will be very
excited about this one and if you have
seen this on Kickstarter you should
check it out because they've been
sharing a lot of really awesome
behind-the-scenes footage
hey everyone my name is Jay Bradley I'm
a creative director and co-founder at
silent our studio in Quebec City Canada
about three months ago we revealed our
next game
through a Kickstarter campaign and we
were blown away by the response our new
game is called sea of stars it's a
turn-based RPG inspired by the retro
classics and so much has happened since
then even though it's only been three
months we have Yasunori Mitsuda at the
kernel triggers composer join the theme
as a guest composer and also we're
working on the playable demo which is
coming out this is just next month's for
backers and we were also invited by
summer game fest to celebrate with them
by putting something together so we were
delighted by the opportunity to work on
an updated trailer to show some of the
polished up animation you've been doing
and also give a bit more screen time to
a character that some people felt
endearing and wanted to see more oh and
so you know with everything going on in
the world it seems our duty as
entertainers finds new purpose and so we
sincerely hope that you will find
enjoyment and this fresh look at
co-stars stay safe everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we tricked you we have one more surprise
it's a world exclusive and it's from the
creator of pin out and smash hit these
are games that have literally been
downloaded hundreds of millions of times
this is the creator's first console
title and it is trippy as hell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it for this installment of day of
the depths but we'll be back in July
with another summer game fest developer
showcase if you're looking to have your
game featured in the next day the babes
will be having an open call for
submissions for the July showcase so
keep your eyes on David Escom for
submissions opening soon thank you as
always to the generous support of our
partners for making all of this possible
Playstation idea Xbox Nintendo epic game
store Steam it takes a village of humans
to make a digital event of this caliber
happen so thank you for all your support
and special thanks to dos 1 rapper poet
composer for lending his sounds to our
soundtrack for today's broadcast his
music is dope check it out
but stay tuned summer game fest
developer showcase is not over yet we've
still got some surprises in store and
thanks you for watching and thanks for
all the developers around the world who
submitted games by watching Thank You
skulls ok let's hope that recorded I
didn't clap that's B in that stream did
you stop yours thank you thank you
you're the best thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
and dose this has been another day of
the dev's production
I am a feed enough
[Applause]
these are the solemn sounds of
more important than any of this [ __ ]
[Music]
is the black lives matter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you